holographic dancers ancient lightsabers
and actors brought back from the dead
are just some of the Star Wars Easter
eggs callbacks and cameos in rogue one
in this video I'm going to look at some
of rogue ones best Star Wars connections
from the original trilogy and prequels
to the animated TV shows rebels and
Clone Wars
obviously there are spoilers ahead for
all things Star Wars related so beware
of that or you can click or tap here for
my spoiler free rogue one review the
infamous surgeon with a death sentence
in 12 systems Cornelius everything is
back in rogue one causing trouble again
and almost picking a fight with Jin and
her friends when they knock into each
other as they're walking by he's on Jada
with Ponda Baba and of course the pair
first appeared in a new hope forever
sanam Ponda Baba deliberately picked a
fight with Luke Skywalker in the Mos
Eisley cantina some of the aliens in
Sargeras cave are playing what looks
like a physical version of the hollow
chest that Chewbacca played on the
Millennium Falcon in a new hope and
which finn accidentally switched on in
the force awakens and saw guerreras cave
contains wealth of fascinating
characters and objects including a nod
to the twi'lek alien allah for Return of
the Jedi look out for the dancing
hologram of Jabba the Hutt's slave
dancer who I shall remember he fed to
his pet rancor in the third film in the
original trilogy one of the aliens we
saw in Sargeras Lair is the alien bizu
fortuna who could be related to bib
Fortuna Jabba the Hutt's major domo biff
fortuna first appeared in Return of the
Jedi when c-3po and r2d2 arrived at
Jabba's palace to deliver a holographic
message from Luke Skywalker and the
inspiration for Obi Wan's Bizu Fortuna
actually came from early Return of the
Jedi models for bib Fortuna saw
Guerrero's words it's a trap when he's
contemplating Galen Urso secret message
and Wai ghin has come to see him now or
a callback to those famous words
exclaimed by Admiral Ackbar in Return of
the Jedi during the Battle of Endor when
the rebel forces are ambushed by the
Empire also in saw guerreras hideout err
Easter eggs two rogue one director
Gareth Edwards previous movies Godzilla
and monsters there are cave paintings of
Godzilla and the Muto from Edwards 2014
movie as well as the aliens from Edwards
first movie monsters chroot my tips his
hat to obi-wan Kenobi when he tries to
tell the stormtroopers on jeder to let
jinn Cassian and Kate Oso
in peace chariot is a strong believer in
the force but his attempted mind trick
doesn't work as it did for obi-wan when
he convinced stormtroopers in Maz Eisley
to let Luke and himself pass by saying
these aren't the droids you're looking
for
Star Wars veteran Warwick Davis who
famously debuted as the Ewok wicket in
Return of the Jedi plays the role of
Wheaties I obey a member of Sargeras
Partizan's
Warwick Davis will be appearing again in
Episode eight and cameo does wala van in
the force awakens and his several
characters in the Phantom Menace and
chest before cronic meets with Darth
Vader we see glimpse of Vader's body
suspended in a back - tank we first saw
a back to tank in the Empire Strikes
Back when it was used to help Luke
Skywalker recover from the wounds he
suffered at the hands of a Whomper on
the icy planet Hoth remember that at the
end of Revenge of the Sith obi-wan
slices off Anakin Skywalker's arms and
legs leaving Anakin horrific Lee scarred
and injured until the emperor has his
missing limbs replaced with mechanical
parts the process is clearly agonizing
for him in an ro1 Vader is presumably
using a bacta tank to keep in good
health Darth Vader's back to tank is
located in a castle on a planet streaked
with lava flows and that planet has been
confirmed as Mustafar by Pablo Hidalgo
from the Lucasfilm story group Mustafar
is the location of Anakin and obi-wan's
fateful duel in Revenge of the Sith and
the idea for having Vader's castle in
such a location actually comes from
unused concept art from the original
trilogy by Ralph McQuarrie and when
Vader forced chokes cranek as his castle
he quips be careful not to choke on your
aspirations director the line ironically
foreshadows Vader's own death in Return
of the Jedi when he asked Luke to remove
his mask despite the fact it's what
helps him breathe by the magic of CGI
and voice technology rogue one brings
back Peter Cushing's image of voices
imperial villain Tarkin we first saw
Tarkin in a new hope where he ordered
the destruction of layers home planet
Alderaan in rogue one Tarkin is
physically played by actor Guy Henry who
you might know from the last Harry
Potter movies and visual effects merge
the actor with Peter Cushing's image
layers adoptive father Bail Organa also
returns having appeared previously in
two of the prequels in rogue one we see
that he made plans to leave Yavin 4 to
go to Alderaan and in a new hope he was
killed when Tarkin
old arounds me the first planet
destroyed by the Death Star in rogue one
Organa is working with another rebel
leader Mon Mothma
who first showed up in Return of the
Jedi with her unforgettable phrase many
Bothans died to bring us this
information
she was played by Caroline Blackistone
in that movie but here she's played by
Genevieve O'Reilly and the resemblance
between the two is remarkable O'Reilly
did already play Mon Mothma in the
prequel Revenge of the Sith however her
scene was cut another rebel leader
general Dodona is played by Ian
McElhinney you might know bear sister
Barristan Selmy in Game of Thrones
general Dodona
previously appeared in a new hope where
he led the rebel attack on the Death
Star and was played by actor Alex Mac
Rendell who died in 1990 during a quick
flashback scene in which we see a young
Jin and her family together with cranek
you can momentarily see the cityscape of
Khorasan through the windows in the
background
by the way the earthers lived on
Coruscant with Galen working for cranek
in the road one novel catalyst anaerobe
Wan also has numerous Easter eggs to the
Star Wars animated TV shows in
particular Star Wars rebels with
Harrison duelers ship the ghost
appearing on Yavin 4 and as the rebels
prepare for the strike on the shield
gates there's also a reference to the
syndulla clan from the rebels TV series
when general syndulla is called to
report to command over the tannoy and
the base on Yavin 4 and also buzzing
around on the rebel base is the cranky
droid chopper he serves on the ghost and
when the Rebel Alliance decide they need
to help June and her rogue crew on
scarab c-3po and r2d2 guess a little
cameo scene with c-3po complaining about
how nobody ever tells him anything and
where would rogue one be without a cameo
from Princess Leia herself who hid the
Death Star plans in r2d2 in a new hope
we see a young Leia in the film thanks
to a combination of motion captured by
actress Engle Dayla and CGI to make her
resemble a young Carrie Fisher by the
way you may have seen ink ville de ella
cameo in another big film that's part of
the Disney family who's actually a world
hub tech in a scene with Robert Downey
jr. in Avengers age of Ultron there's
also a cameo by Star Wars rebels and
Clone Wars voice actor Steven Stanton
who provided the voice for Tarkin in
those animated shows in rogue one he
voices the Mon Calamari character
Admiral Radice and the hammerhead
Corvette is another Star Wars rebels
ship
which itself is a version of a ship from
the Knights of the Old Republic video
game and in rogue one it ended up being
key to the rebels successful destruction
of the scary shield gate in fact the
idea of you using the hammerhead
Corvette to batter together two imperial
star destroyers to smash through the
shield gate was actually adapted from an
unused idea from the force awakens
concept art from episode 7 shows the
idea of a huge Warhammer ship being used
to penetrate star kilobases planetary
shield rogue ones to Rutten Bay's also
introduced us to the guardians of the
Wills the Wills was George Lucas's
original term for the force and he also
planned to use the journal of the Wills
as part of a subtitle for Star Wars
rogue one also introduces us to Kyber
crystals something has already been
explored in the Clone Wars and rebels TV
shows but not yet in the movies the
Empire has occupied Jeddah so it can
strip mine the moon of its Kyber
crystals which it needs to power the
Death Star's weapon in Star Wars Canon
Kyber crystals are used by Jedi to
construct their lightsabers and
typically a crystal will turn green or
blue wants chosen because crystals are
inherently aligned with the light side
of the force
a Sith has to overpower a crystal with
their own will which causes it to bleed
giving a sitz lightsaber its distinctive
red color and during a rebel attack on
Scarab a couple of stormtroopers wander
past having a conversation about T 15s
becoming obsolete well that's a little
easter egg to the conversation that a
couple of stormtroopers had in a new
hope about the vt6 teens and which was
also referenced in the force awakens by
a pair of stormtroopers talking about
the t-17s by the way cameo as a
stormtrooper in a rogue one stunt scene
is the enigmatic former Stig from Top
Gear and it's amusing that he's back as
another silent helmet clad character all
in white also caring as a bad guy is
Star Wars Episode 8 director Rian
Johnson who appears in this shot where
he and fellow producer Ram Bergman a
Death Star operators shielding
themselves from the deadly rain and
there's an easter egg to an ancient
weapon when jyn erso is checking through
the code names of various data files
inside the Scarab control tower one of
the names which crops up his black saber
which is a reference to the dark saber
her black bladed lightsaber that
originally
belong to the Jedi Order the dark saber
has featured in the Clone Wars TV series
where it was wielded by the Mandalorian
previz Allah until Darth Maul took it
from him and after the last episode of
Star Wars rebels that aired before the
theatrical release of rogue one the dark
saber is in the hands of Sabine Wren a
Mandalorian member of the ghost crew
before Ginn gets inside the control
tower on Skerritt gin castle and Ketu
enter an elevator and just before the
door closes we get to hear que to say
that classic Star Wars line I've got a
bad feeling about this
rogue one also has a bit of fun with a
line as Cassy and cuts Katie off just
before he can finish it telling the
Droid to be quiet and inside the tower
there's a callback to a new hope when
katie gets into a sticky situation with
imperial troopers just like c-3po and
r2d2 run in with them on the Death Star
in Episode four c-3po trick some
stormtroopers after they stormed into
the control room where he and r2d2 were
hiding
c-3po sent the stormtroopers off
claiming that the real infiltrators had
left for the prison level k2 tried a
similar tactic on the Imperial troopers
when they found him in the control room
sadly for k2 though casseon blew his
cover by speaking over the comlink
k2 eso's love of quoting statistical
probabilities and his being told by
Kathy Anne that he doesn't want to know
is another amage to c-3po has twice in
the Empire Strikes Back Threepio
infuriates Han Solo when he starts
citing chances of survival on re 7
protocol droid like 3 B that was in the
Jawa sandcrawler on Tatooine with c-3po
and r2d2 turns up in rogue one during
one of the scarf interior scenes and
there are also appearances in the film
from other classic Star Wars droids such
as gonk and mouse droids there's also a
nod to the blue milk which we first saw
in a new hope in Luke Skywalker's home
on Tatooine when we get a glimpse of
some blue milk and the Urso family home
on the planet la Moo it's interesting
that the arose in the prologue and
Luke's family on Tatooine are all
farmers when cronic goes to e do to
confront Galen and his team about the
leaked message from the research
facility
Galen stands up to chronic and tells him
you'll never win - which cranek replies
now worth I heard that before
this is a little meta moment and
reference to Obi Wan's final words to
Darth Vader in a new hope
you can't win Darth if you strike me
down I shall become more powerful than
you can possibly imagine and director
Gareth Edwards has revealed that the
planet II do was inspired by the
original alien movie the dark and stormy
II do certainly burns a number of
similarities to the alien moon lv-426
during the rebel attack on the scary
shields gate you might have noticed some
footage that looked uncannily familiar
the parts of the pilots red leader and
gold leader were played by the original
actors from a new hope drew Henley and
Angus MacInnes their scenes in rogue one
were actually archive footage that was
cut from Episode four and carefully
spliced into the new movie road one is
also littered with references to a new
hope to certain versions of themes and
scenes from Episode four here's some to
look out for rogue one begins with
cronic dressed in white arriving on lamu
surrounded by death troopers clad in
black armor in contrast to the beginning
of a new hope which starts with the
black clad Darth Vader entering the
tanti for surrounded by stormtroopers in
white armor in robe one layers tan t4
escapes out of the hold of a much larger
ship which echoes in Reverse the
beginning of a new hope with a tan team
four is pulled into the hold of Darth
Vader's Star Destroyer so guys what
other Easter eggs or cool Star Wars
references did you spot and what was
your favorite moment in rogue one if you
enjoyed this do please like it and share
and subscribe for more movie videos like
this and in the meantime you can check
out some more of my videos you might
like here thanks for watching and see
you next time yippee-ki-yay movie lovers